check
chess is a game of unlimited beauty but
it's not
just checks and attacks you have to be
creative
i'm here to share with you my knowledge
of the game of chess
but i'm trying to come up with the
comprehensive picture that will be
helpful for you
to become a better chess player and even
a better decision maker
let's cover king g5 king c2 king f6 king
b3 king is 7 king c4 king d6 king b5
king c7 king a6
boom white lost yes
queen takes then knight f5 and it's a
double attack
skewer and attraction and it's made
what an amazing mate how can we
prevent this rook from stopping our pawn
let's pause stop the video and think
okay you have time to find this
winning combination did you see that
your bishop was hanging what is that
you have not seen no i didn't see that
line that's that's interesting so you
attack my bishop and then you
protect your bishop right so let's go
back and see
whether we can improve and uh what's the
next logical moves
it's about coming up with new ideas
challenging your own excellence
you find your mistakes next time you
have to do better i've been thinking
about few ideas that i never used the
one i want to show
it's another sacrifice i like sacrifices
and it's one of my favorite openings so
just let's have a look
we cannot waste time time is precious
if you don't feel that the game can
unleash your creative potential
then you're ready on the losing side
it's not about winning or losing
but of course at the end of the day it's
about when it comes
i'm gary kasparov and this is my master
class
you